hi i'm justice smith and i play chester
hi i'm chase lee wonders i play riley
hey i'm nikita maxwell i play delilah hi
i'm nathania alexander and i play ariana
hi
my name is haley sanchez and i play
greta hi my name is julie schlesinger
and i play nathan
hi my name is chloe east and i play
naomi
and today we're here with buzzfeed to
play
who's who
who's most likely to be caught taking a
selfie i'm gonna say
me only because i'm in character
on set and chester takes a lot of
selfies so i take a lot of selfies
julie has very piercing eyes he is
constantly looking at his selfie camera
no nathania i would say
justice i would also say just oh i would
say
i would say chloe chloe
though she'll like be like okay the
lighting's good here's my phone can you
take a couple photos she knows her life
the sister is not wrong about that
i mean
i'm always looking for a good photo
moment on set
who's the best at giving relationship
advice
me just gonna save me
is that narcissistic lukita is very wise
she's the youngest of us but she's
incredibly wise
haley hayley i didn't say anyone
i feel too loyal to all my friends on
the show i don't want to insult anyone
so i don't know it's everyone
i feel like keith is the only person
i've gotten relationship advice
from so that isn't the only person that
i can
i only said haley because haley just
gives good advice in general
so i feel so flattered
who's most like their generation
character
i'm a lot like my character one i'm a
leo and i'm a narcissist
i just think of myself every single with
every single question
i'm just like yeah i gotta do that maybe
haley
or lukita chloe
you have to be joking you have to be
joking
you were born to play naomi it's
perfect it is perfect i grew up in
orange county that is true
naomi would throw up if she looked at my
overalls i wear every day
my car i have or anything yeah that's
true
that's very true but i i think she would
like taco bell oh
that's very cool yeah and i feel like
naomi likes taco bell she's so good on
instagram
and i don't have snapchat or tick tock
who is
least like their generation character
yulie
maybe is least like his generation
character yulie is i
i think a lot more self-assured than
than nathan is
nathan is a just kind of he's not
pathetic but
he's just kind of like simply and i i
don't feel like you always like that but
maybe
nathania
that's not true that is a lie nathania
is just like that
i am nothing like ariana she's crazy
it's fun to play her as an actor because
like she has
zero filter who is the best at doing
impressions of other cast members
i gotta say i think it might be me
chase hey chase hey
hands down chase chase does the
impressions of everybody
she's so good at them she's so good at
it she like embodies the physicalities
yeah like her that's not only the cast
for everybody on set
she really goes for it there was a
dinner that we did and chase
was doing impressions of everybody
around the table yeah that was very
early on and the impressions like have
evolved as we've gotten to know each
other better
keita when she speaks she gets really
spirited and she uses like a lot of
hand gestures and she intonates her
voice
to add emphasis julie has a very
specific sort of like kind of snarky
playful laugh
where he flares his nostrils and because
these all have off cameras you have to
really know these tricks specifically
these maybe it will not land who's most
likely to learn a tick tock dance and
perform it flawlessly
probably justice he's a really good
dancer no
honestly nathania nathaniel's a really
good dancer
and i could see her performing
flawlessly
that's actually honestly keita is on
tick tock a lot a lot but not in the
tick tock dance
world i don't really watch tick tock
dances i'm more on like the tick tock
comedy side of things peta did a britney
tick tock dance or like she had five
seconds to learn it and she performed
flawlessly
so after seeing that before my eyes it's
keto
i can't really dance though that's the
thing i feel like my
my energy says that i would do that but
i can't really dance
i feel like chester could do this though
he does everything so
like confidently like he can watch
something
and absolutely know the energy that
needs to be embodied in that moment
and so if he's thrown something he's
going to get up and he's going to
just absolutely deliver and absolutely
kill it who's most likely to introduce
you
to a band or musician you've never heard
of
shane
i also said kita i said haley i could
see that
yulie he introduced me to this band
midair thief that i'm in love with now
julie julie's music taste is impeccable
he always has a song he wants to play
for everybody
he showed me the song baby powder just
so good and so soulful
and race car two two very fun songs he
showed me recently
chase is always telling me some like
weird weird music
italian stuff the flip from everyone
yeah i feel like we all have a really
diverse taste in music
like yeah in our own music that we
listen to so whenever we listen to music
together it's
really all over the place yeah or or
just like
when we're in the same car together and
someone has the ox cord
when you had the ox core newly we would
drive home together
um julie and keita yuli would play
like songs and i would be like oh what's
that song i need it on my playlist
who's most likely to break character
during a take i
i can't i don't i don't know i think
everyone kind of
is really professional and doesn't
really break characters that much
maybe me chloe chloe
really yeah the amount of times that i
broke character
it makes me very upset
we shot something a couple days ago and
you you really you stayed in it for a
long time
and you did it mad long and i was like
she is still going that is true it's
mostly when someone else breaks or
someone else does something funny in the
scene i can't take it
if i'm the joke in the scene i feel like
it's easier for me to
stay in character and like not break but
it's like
when i see nathania you know do
something that
cracks me up like we shot a scene last
week where
they had a reset like four times because
i could not stop laughing it was bad
i was like let's give them a second i
was just
dying a lot of the time when you start
laughing
you still stay in character and your
character improv
is impeccable like when you stay in
naomi you are
in nails chloe does do a really good job
at you think she's broken but actually
it's just part of her character
to just like laugh at like the stupid
people are doing
and it will be seamless who's most
likely to drop everything to help a
friend in need
oh that's nice maybe haley or lukita
nikita is very nurturing in that way too
justice
yeah very good friend everyone would
drop what they're doing to help it
yeah i feel like i can call any of you
guys
really guys if ever i'm
freaking out about something i can just
text either of you guys and be like
i'm freaking out out about this and both
of you guys would like drop
everything get on the phone with me and
talk i said kita cause
you're all literally always there
even when like it's a tough scene or
like
i don't even need to say anything you
can feel it and you're like
hey are you good do you need anything
you know i'm here
i said chloe because i feel like he's
like such an approachable person and
just like
very open to just take you in give you
it like a very like
you're not hugging but you're you're
actually hugging even though you're like
right next to each other kind of vibe
it's like he's a person that's like
like very there for you if you need your
tubing this is so mushy
nobody said me but that's fine
who's most likely to be caught napping
between scenes nathan
peter chloe i
have found the sleeper and scene so
haley it was that one time
lukita has a really impressive ability
to fall asleep
i just spotted her once and she had
passed out and she had like
i think like on her backpack and she had
like marks on her cheek
and i took like a five minute nap like
on the floor
and i woke up and haley like walks into
the room and i just have the rug print
on my face and she was like you were
taking a nap weren't you
i do know chloe likes to take her space
between steve so
who's most likely to pull a prank on set
yes
justice yeah i just like [ __ ] with
people sometimes but i don't know if
it should be though maybe julie julie is
just very
he's very jokey between i mean we all
are very jokey between takes but
i think you only specifically like he's
those are very he up to the last second
you can be out of character joking
around and then this is as soon as the
cameras get
i just feel like he's so mischievous
yeah and he'll get everyone always up
there
like yeah he's got an idea he's just
like come on like you guys